>> CONGRATULATIONS AND HERE'S TO
THE NEXT 75 SEASONS FULL OF
SHINING STARS.
>> NOW EVERYBODY, EVERYBODY ON
YOUR FEET!
EVERYBODY GET IN BEAT, COME ON,
COME ON.
EVERYBODY ON YOUR FEET.
COME ON, COME ON.
EVERYBODY ON YOUR FEET!
♪ CAN YOU FEEL IT, COME ON AND
WAVE THOSE HANDS ♪
♪ CAN YOU FEEL IT ♪
♪ LISTEN, WHEN YOU WISH UPON A
STAR ♪
♪ DREAMS WILL TAKE YOU VERY FAR,
YEAH ♪
♪ WHEN YOU WISH UPON A DREAM,
LIFE AIN'T ALWAYS WHAT IT SEEMS
OH YEAH ♪
♪ WHAT YOU SEE IS NOT SO CLEAR,
IT'S SO VERY DEAR ♪
♪ YOU'RE A SHINING STAR, NO
MATTER WHO YOU ARE ♪
♪ SHINING BRIGHT TO SEE WHAT YOU
CAN TRULY BE ♪
♪ YOU'RE A SHINING STAR, NO
MATTER WHO YOU ARE ♪
♪ SHINING BRIGHT TO SEE WHAT YOU
CAN TRULY BE ♪
♪ YOU'RE A SHINING STAR, NO
MATTER WHO YOU ARE ♪
♪ SHINING BRIGHT TO SEE WHO YOU
CAN TRULY BE ♪
>> EVERYBODY, SING.
HONOR THESE LEGENDS.
EVERYBODY SING.
COME ON, COME ON.
WHOO!
PUT YOUR HANDS TOGETHER!
♪ SHINING STAR FOR YOU LIFE CAN♪
♪ SHINING STAR FOR YOU TO SEE
WHAT YOUR LIFE CAN TRULY BE ♪
>> DON'T STOP, DON'T STOP.
COME ON AND GIVE IT TO 'EM,
Y'ALL.
>> STOP, STOP.
>> COME ON, SHINING STAR.
>> WHAT YOUR LIFE.
>> SHINING